under pressure following an emergency
meeting of g7 leaders to discuss
extending the afghanistan withdrawal
date u.s president joe biden was adamant
u.s troops will be out by august 31st
the sooner we can finish the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
still u.s withdrawal from afghanistan
relies on taliban cooperation to ensure
kabul's airport remains open if not
biden says he's directed the pentagon to
draw up contingency plans
more than 75 thousand people have been
evacuated since mid-july thousands more
afghan and u.s civilians still surround
hamad karzai international hoping to
board one of the dozens of u.s flights
out of the country but escaped chances
are diminishing when house intelligence
committee members said bluntly not all
who want to leave will make biden's
deadline we have to get american
citizens out and we have to get our
afghan partners and allies out the
american people support it and their
representatives in this house support it
that can't be accomplished between now
and the end of the month
the pentagon says it's increased its
pace with planes of evacuees taking off
approximately every 45 minutes the
rescue effort is being done with a sense
of urgency while taliban commanders are
currently communicating with u.s forces
there's no guarantee that will continue
afghanistan is a dangerous place right
now which is why we're trying to move as
many americans as we can as fast as we
can
on monday biden dispatched his top spy
cia director william burns to meet with
taliban officials about a possible
deadline extension the proposal was
rejected
the firm august 31st afghanistan
withdrawal has led to bipartisan and
global criticism of the u.s president we
need at least a couple more weeks three
to four more weeks i find it hard to
believe that the taliban will not give
in on this point they're making
statements to the contrary but they're
going to be in need of financial
assistance and the critical issue of
recognition following discussions with
nato the un eu and g7 leaders biden says
the international community is committed
to ensuring the taliban keeps its word
and won't allow afghanistan to once
again become a training ground for
attacks on the united states or its
allies we agree that none of us
are going to take the taliban's word for
it
we'll judge them by their actions
the u.s military could begin withdrawing
some of the 6 000 currently securing the
kabul airport by the end of the week but
the broader evacuations are still
ongoing and the white house says that
will continue right up until the end of
the month
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house